we are now joined by dr ashish jah he's
dean of brown university school of
public health
dr jean very good to see you again this
morning thank you for joining us
good morning gail thanks for having me
on yeah we're glad to have you here
let's start well let's pick up where uh
david left off about getting the vaccine
we can all agree that it's been an epic
fail
but now as we move forward the biden
administration of course wants to
correct that they're saying
100 million shots in the first 100 days
sounds very ambitious do you think it's
doable
you know gail i do i do think it's
doable i think
what the biden team has laid out as a
plan is
somebody described it maddeningly
obvious it's just it's basic public
health it's the federal government
helping the states
it's getting more vaccine sites set up i
think if we do all of that i think we
can do a million shots a day
uh over the next three months you know
we were talking at the table and david's
report they said you
they're going to set up a facility in a
garage is that okay with you
tony decouple said i'll take it wherever
however is that okay with you me too
and tony anthony mason said the same
i i'm with you guys i i feel like look
um we want to set it up anywhere where
it's safe to do so you want to have
space where people can come
they can get their vaccine and i i like
the idea of setting it up
in you know in stadiums and in gyms and
all of that is great as long as we make
it accessible to the american people
so as we sit here today less than half
of all the vaccine doses that have been
shipped
have been administered why is that
happening and how do we close the gap
yes i think first of all things are
starting to get better i think the
reason
is there was no federal planning
whatsoever basically they
gave the vaccines to states but states
didn't have any resources they didn't
have much in the way of planning
states are figuring it out and they're
starting to get going
and i think we'll see this even ramp up
further once the federal government gets
involved and starts helping states
when do you expect that the vaccine will
be available for everybody
that's a great question gail you know i
think yeah i i will i
think um majority of americans should
start seeing it be available for them in
april to may if everything goes well
obviously that could slip to june but
certainly by summer time i think anybody
who wants a vaccine should be able to
get one
okay listen i just want to hear any date
any date at all because before we had
none
but what do you make of the the new
strains we keep hearing about are you
concerned about them
these viral and strains that are now
signing in
yeah you know i am actually really
concerned about them certainly the uk
variant really concerns me because it's
so much more contagious and it's going
to end up dominating
the infections in the united states we
have a real race right now
these variants are starting to take off
across the country
and our job is to get as many people
vaccinated and protected as possible
uh before those variants really become
dominant and start infecting a lot of
people
all right dr ashish always good to see
you thank you for your time today